ah hi I'm Tom the lead game designer for
tribal wars 2 and today I want to talk
about units and some tactics for the
battle system
of course the bellow system and that's
why vastu is similar to the old one so
still all old tactics will work and we
have two kinds of units there are the
offensive units and the defensive units
of course the defensive units are for
defending your village and offensive
units are for attacking other villages
or plundering by burying villages to get
resources we have now 13 units
especially there two new units have
special abilities so the trebuchet for
example is they have to counter enemy
attacks with siege weapons because the
trebuchet is able to destroy siege
weapons before they enter battle so the
enemy attacks is thousand grams then you
only need 2000 trebuchet in your village
and the Rams are gone before they could
enter or reach your wall the Berserker
which is a nice new offensive unit
because it will fight at or fight with
more power if the is fighting against a
superior
the generals are for more experienced
players they allow players to perform
different tactics that aren't able in
the old tribal wars the simplest one is
that they can erase the attack power a
bit plunder more or like the hospital
building which is for the defender that
heals unit after the battle you've got
an in general that's the medic and it
does the same for the attacker so after
the battle he resurrects some units and
they will march back and the religion
can fight again my favorite unit of
course the Berserker the new unit
because I like the artwork and I like
the way they behave in battle